Du coup, tu voudrais qu’on se marie à l’église ?
Oula, c’est pas un peu tôt pour ça ?
Je ne sais pas si je suis prête.
Et tu ne sais pas tout sur moi.
Rien de ce que tu fais ne manque de grâce, ça je le sais.
J’ai quand même enterré ma cousine dans la forêt, et c’était pas un enterrement très très chrétien.
- Ah ?
- Tu le gardes pour toi, hein ?
J’étais avec Florence et Monté.
À priori, c’est Un Créatif qui l’a tué, mais il ne l’a pas fait exprès quoi.
Ça a vraiment été une épreuve.
Mais bon, je suis contente qu’on puisse se soutenir dans les épreuves.
Pas vrai ?
Oui...
C’est un argument que vous entendez beaucoup sur une partie du spectre politique, et ce serait une vérité sociale.
La France est un pays chrétien, un pays catholique même.
On la surnomme même “la fille aînée de l’église”, puisque Clovis fut le premier roi baptisé.
D’ailleurs, les rois de France portent depuis Charles V le titre de “Très Chrétien”, c’est dire si on n'est pas comme cul et chemise avec les curés depuis un bon bout de temps.
Mais moi, je ne suis pas catholique.
Je ne sais même pas si je suis chrétien, d’ailleurs.
Et force est de constater que la majeure partie de mon cercle est dans la même situation que moi.
Du coup, ça me fait me poser une question toutes ces histoires :
la France est-elle encore chrétienne ?
En France, la collecte d’information relative à la confession est interdite lors des recensements officiels, il n’y a donc
aucun moyen de savoir précisément combien de personnes se déclarent chrétiennes ou catholiques.
Il reste toujours les sondages pour se faire une idée, mais qui donnent des résultats assez variables quand cela touche à la question religieuse.
Selon comme l’on pose la question, la part de chrétiens reste importante ou représente désormais une minorité.
Notons quand même un consensus :
l’extrême majorité des chrétiens en France sont catholiques, la part de protestante étant très faible et celle des orthodoxes encore plus faible.
Du coup, je vais reformuler mon énoncé : la France est-elle encore catholique ?
Selon un sondage ifop relayé par l’Express en 2016,
la France comptait celle année-là 65% de catholiques, contre 87% en 1972.
Comme je n’ai pas pu avoir le détail du sondage en question, je me suis rendu sur stastista.com pour trouver d’autres sondages confessionnels,
et si on prend cette enquête de 2018 comme source,
à la question à quelle religion vous sentez-vous lié,
le catholicisme tombe à 48%.
On passe donc de deux-tiers à moins de la moitié.
La différence est énorme.
Dans un article du Point de 2018, basé sur les analyses de deux sociologues, on tombe même à 32%.
On tombe à moins d’un tiers des français, donc.
Pour expliquer cette importante variance, c’est peut-être parce que la question, finalement,
c’est de savoir ce que ça veut dire “être catholique”.
Et sa réponse, elle a beaucoup évolué.
Alors que l’institut de sondage ifop prenait comme indicateur le nombre de personnes allant à la messe pour estimer le nombre de catholiques dans les années 60,
ce chiffre étant devenu trop bas, il a dû changer d’indicateur et donc la réponse à cette question pour continuer ses sondages.
Désormais, le nombre de catholiques est purement basé sur le déclaratif et ce depuis le début des années 2000.
Et il se trouve que pour la majorité des personnes interrogées se déclarant catholique, “être catholique” veut dire pas mal de choses différentes.
Pour la majorité d’entre eux, cela signifie avant tout d’avoir été baptisé, par exemple.
A peine plus de la moitié considère qu’il faille croire en la résurrection du christ pour être catholique, et moins d’un tiers considère qu’aller à la messe soit un facteur nécessaire.
Mais il se trouve que moi, j’ai été baptisé.
J’ai même été communié.
Comme je ne crois pas en Dieu, je ne pense pas être catholique pour autant.
C’est vrai qu’à mes yeux, ce dernier critère vient avant tous les autres.
Mais contre toute attente, pour se définir comme catholique, avoir vécu un rite comme le baptême semble plus important qu’avoir la foi.
En vrai, je suis guère surpris, si vous déménagez en Autriche,
si l’état met la main sur votre certificat de baptême en en faisant la demande à votre diocèse par exemple,
vous serez forcé de payer des impôts sur le culte catholique peu importe que vous vous déclariez athée ou agnostique.
Il faudra se faire débaptiser, plusieurs amis en ont fait les frais quand j’y habitais.
Y a un côté très matérialiste, mais le document qui vous lie métaphoriquement à cette religion sera plus important que la religion que vous déclarez comme la vôtre à l’état civil.
Parce que oui.
En Autriche, et comme dans pas mal de pays du monde d’ailleurs, la religion est à mentionner sur vos impôts,
dans votre CV ou même si jamais vous voulez vous inscrire à l’université par exemple.
Je suis sûr que tu crois en Dieu toi.
Peut-être que je suis chrétienne.
- Enfin j’ai une éducation chrétienne...
- Ouais nan, c'est chiant. Thibaut ?
- Alors...
- Ouais nan tu vas nous citer quatre philosophes. Léa, peut-être...
J’allais juste dire “non”.
Je sais pas ? Qu’est-ce que tu veux dire par chrétien ?
En France, on a guère que les sondages pour faire nos comptes.
Sauf que moi, le déclaratif ça m’ennuie, surtout si personne ne répond à la question selon les mêmes critères.
J’en veux pour exemple que l’on divise désormais les catholiques entre ceux qui sont du côté de la foi, c’est-à-dire les croyants ou les pratiquants,
et ceux qui sont du côté des rites,
c’est-à-dire ceux qui se considèrent comme tel par tradition
et qui pour beaucoup ne croient même plus en Dieu.
Alors, on peut chercher d’autres indicateurs.
Le mariage religieux par exemple.
En 2017, le nombre de mariages à l’église catholique ne représentait que 22% des mariages célébrés en France.
C’est deux fois moins qu’en 2003, et quatre fois moins  qu’en 1955.
Mais encore une fois, ce chiffre englobe également des non-catholiques qui veulent aller jusqu’à l’autel pour s’unir par tradition,
ou des couples mixtes dans leur foi qui acceptent cette cérémonie pour faire plaisir à la famille de l’autre partenaire.
J’ai moi-même été récemment invité au mariage à l’église d’un ami qui est athée.
Alors un indicateur plus fiable, cela pourrait être celui des enfants inscrits au catéchisme, c’est-à-dire ceux qui suivent une instruction religieuse.
De mon temps, dans ma région, le pays Langrois,
le catéchisme était forcément proposé dans un cadre extrascolaire,
les parents devaient alors s’organiser eux-mêmes pour faire le caté,
et évidemment donc s’organiser pour nous amener ou nous ramener à l’endroit ou cette activité était dispensée,
car c’était rarement dans le même village.
En me basant sur ce vécu, j’ai donc émis le postulat que l’inscription au catéchisme relevait d’une démarche active
et donc d’un témoignage des parents de leur volonté de transmettre leur foi à leurs enfants.
Et il se trouve que seuls 17% des enfants étaient catéchisés en 2016, contre 42% en 1993.
C’est trois fois moins.
En moyenne, ce chiffre continuerait à baisser d’environ 1% par an.
Mais cet indicateur n’est pas idéal non plus, les écoles privées catholiques proposent presque toujours la catéchèse,
c’est-à-dire des cours de catéchisme.
Or, il y a des régions où l’enseignement privé est très implanté, comme en Bretagne où 39% des écoles, 43% des collégiens et 41% des lycées y sont rattachées.
Fatalement, chez nos amis bretons, plus d’un enfant sur deux suit le catéchisme.
Pour autant, ces enfants sont-ils tous catholiques ?
Evidemment, non.
Aujourd’hui, l’école privée n’est plus convoitée parce qu’elle te parle de Jésus,
elle l’est pour tout un tas d’autres raisons.
À Lille, certaines écoles catholiques ont même une majorité d’élèves musulmans.
Si en tout cas ni le baptême ni la communion ne sont de bons indicateurs, bien qu’ils soient les deux premiers sacrements,
on peut toujours regarder les chiffres du troisième sacrement, c’est-à-dire la confirmation.
En 2017, seules 45.000 confirmations ont été faites, c’est deux fois moins qu’en 1990 alors que la France compte pourtant
10 millions d’habitants en plus.
Pour finir, un autre chiffre important : celui du nombre de prêtres.
La France comptait 29.000 prêtres en 1995, ce nombre est tombé à 15.000 en 2015.
Moitié moins en 20 ans, quand même.
Parmi ces 15.000 dévoués au service liturgique,
deux-tiers ont plus de 65 ans, et presque la moitié plus de 75 ans.
La France perd donc dans les 800 prêtres par an, essentiellement par décès,
alors que seule une centaine d’ordination sont prononcées.
En quelques décennies, on est passé de la figure centrale dans le tissu social
à une denrée qui chaque jour devient plus rare.
Bref, si on ne peut pas savoir combien de chrétiens la France compte avec exactitude, ni mesurer sa baisse de manière fiable, elle existe bien et elle est forte.
Et surtout, elle semble avoir été très rapide.
La démographie actuelle devrait continuer à accélérer la déchristianisation.
Seuls 3% des 18-29 ans seraient catholiques pratiquants en France, pas de quoi combler les trous.
Mais du coup, ça date de quand ?
Est-ce que c’est vraiment si récent que ça la déchristianisation ?
Eh bien, si on peut avoir l’impression que ça date d’aujourd’hui, ça date en réalité plutôt d’hier.
La période des lumières est un bon point de début à la déchristianisation en France.
On trouve durant cette période la défense ou l’émergence de courants spirituels qui questionnent la doctrine chrétienne, comme le déisme qui cherche à rationaliser l’existence de Dieu.
Rousseau et Voltaire s’inscrivent dans la démarche déiste, qui a des airs de panthéisme chez ce dernier.
Pour Voltaire, tout est Dieu, et son existence est impossible à nier.
Pour autant, aucune incarnation de Dieu n’est selon lui possible. Comme il l’écrira lui-même à ce sujet :
« Un Dieu se joindre à la nature humaine !
J'aimerais autant dire que les éléphants ont fait l'amour à des puces,
et en ont eu de la race,
ce serait bien moins impertinent ».
Cela élimine d’un revers de main le messie, l’immaculé conception, la trinité. Coup dur pour Jésus et ses disciples.
Cette période coïncide avec l’émergence d’un athéisme assumé.
Jean Meslier, prêtre rattaché à l'archidiocèse de Reims,
est certainement le premier clerc français à critiquer radicalement l’église au point de défendre l’athéisme sans concession.
Voyez par vous même ce qu’il a écrit dans son testament :
« toutes les religions du monde ne sont que des inventions humaines,
et que tout ce que votre religion vous enseigne, et vous oblige de croire, comme surnaturel et divin,
n’est dans le fond qu’erreur, que mensonge, qu’illusion et imposture. »
Venant d’un curé de campagne,
ça la fout mal quand même.
Faudrait aller me couper quelques arbres là-bas pour une charpente.
Mais pour quoi faire ?
Pour construire une église dans le champ là-bas, pour racheter mes péchés.
T'es sérieux ?
Selon toi ?
OK.
Les idées critiques des Lumières sur la religion, qui mettent à mal le christianisme, conduisent à la déchristianisation politique,
c’est-à-dire aux politiques publiques qui cherchent à contrôler ou éliminer le christianisme.
La première démonstration dans les grandes largeurs, on la trouve durant la Révolution française.
L’église catholique est vue comme complice de l’aristocratie et de l’absolutisme.
Faut dire qu’elle cherche à contrôler la libre-pensée, en censurant les livres qui la prônent un peu trop par exemple.
Ça passe mal.
Alors après la prise de la Bastille, on met fin aux privilèges fiscaux du clergé.
Mais les révolutionnaires ne s’arrêtent pas là :
contrôle du port du costume ecclésiastique,
interdiction des manifestations religieuses en public,
changement de calendrier pour ne plus avoir comme date d’origine la naissance de Jésus Christ,
laïcisation des services funéraires et des cimetières...
Notre-Dame de Paris devient même un “temple de la raison”,
et l’on y célèbre  des fêtes laïques.
Plusieurs villes ont été débaptisées ou renommées pour éliminer les références religieuses.
Villedieu est renommée la Carmagnole,
Saint-Ouen devient Bains-sur-Seine.
Si on trouve des initiatives visant à réduire la suprématie du catholicisme, pour autant, la politique religieuse n’est pas uniforme ni toujours très claire.
Plusieurs courants cohabitent et se confrontent, toutes les mesures prises ne plaisent pas, et les divisions sur les questions de culte provoquent des troubles.
Les choses évoluent radicalement avec l’arrivée de Napoléon au pouvoir, quelques années plus tard.
L’église fait son grand retour dans la vie civique.
C’est l’occasion pour l’empereur de calmer ces troubles induits par la Révolution. Cependant, Napoléon ne cherche pas pour autant à restaurer le pouvoir ecclésiastique,
puisque c’est aussi un moyen de le mettre sous tutelle de et s’en servir pour légitimer son pouvoir.
D’ailleurs, Napoléon finira par être excommunié : c’est la plus grosse sanction possible dans l’église catholique.
Théoriquement, l’excommunication vous prive des sacrements, de sépulture chrétienne et expose tous les autres catholiques qui vous fréquenteraient
à eux-mêmes être excommuniés.
Il faut dire que l’empereur a annexé les États pontificaux, Rome sa capitale devient un vulgaire chef-lieu départemental.
En réaction à cette peine canonique, Napoléon se démonte pas et fait même déporter le pape qui se retrouve en résidence surveillée.
Il lui interdit de communiquer avec les évêques de l’Empire français, ce qui coupe le pouvoir pontifical de ceux qui lui doivent obéissance.
Que ce soit Les révolutionnaires ou Napoléon, il existe alors un objectif commun.
Réduire l’influence du pape sur la société française.
Et pour se faire, une question centrale doit être tranchée :
doit-on séparer l’église de l'État,
ou au contraire la mettre sous tutelle de l'État pour la libérer de l’influence étrangère ?
Moi je vais parler à ce volume-là. À peu près.
7.5 1.2
Du coup, 1905, c’est la loi de la séparation des Églises et de l’État.
C’est super important de dire églises au pluriel d’ailleurs.
C’est l’État qui dit : « On ne reconnait aucune religion en particulier ».
Le christianisme n’a pas plus de place que n’importe quelle autre religion. On a un État laïque.
On est neutre par rapport à la religion.
Par contre, ce qui est intéressant de savoir, c’est que l’Alsace-Lorraine a un régime un peu différent,
puisqu’il y a des fêtes religieuses qui sont reconnues et considérées comme des jours fériés là-bas,
et pas dans le reste de la France.
Et c’est pareil pour la Guyane.
Ça, je l’ai appris, y a pas longtemps.
Mais alors du coup, s’il y a séparation des Églises et de l’État, ça ne t’a pas échappé que Notre Dame de Paris a brûlé,
et que ça va être restauré.
Et l’État va en prendre à priori une partie à sa charge.
C’est Emmanuel Macron qui a pris la décision de comment allait être reconstruite la flèche.
Pourquoi s’il y a séparation de l’Église et de l’État,
un truc comme Notre Dame de Paris, l’État a son mot à dire par exemple.
C’est du patrimoine. Du patrimoine historique.
Et du coup, quand tu rénoves une église ou une cathédrale,
tu ne subventionnes pas une religion en fait. C’est du patrimoine qui appartient à tout le monde.
Et du coup, c’est important d’entretenir ce patrimoine-là.
C’est pour ça que l’État le finance.
Mais l'ambiguïté est plutôt compréhensible en fait. En 1905, on dit juste, on a un État laïque.
Sauf que de plus en plus, on a cultivé une façon de concevoir la laïcité comme la neutralité la plus totale.
Sauf que ce n’est pas parce que tu as un État laïque, que tu es forcément neutre.
Par exemple, nos fonctionnaires ne doivent pas porter la kippa, la croix, le voile ou autre chose.
Mais ce n’est pas le cas partout. Au Canada par exemple, tu as des policières qui porte un niqab
et ça ne pose pas particulièrement de soucis.
Dans l’esprit de la loi de 1905,
on n'avait pas forcément conçu la laïcité en ce sens.
Et c’est marrant, parce qu’on a l’impression que laïcité égal forcément neutralité
alors qu’en fait, le débat, il est beaucoup plus nuancé.
Parce que les politiques ont fait l’amalgame, mais je me souviens très bien qu’à la fac de droit,
on avait des profs qui disaient,
je ne vois pas en quoi la laïcité justifierait qu’on interdise le voile
à l’école, à la fac ou ce genre de choses.
Il y avait vraiment un débat juridique
en termes de comment est-ce qu’on estime que la laïcité doit s’appliquer maintenant.
C’est marrant comme entre l’esprit dans lequel on a fait la loi en 1905
et ce qu’on en fait à l’heure actuelle, y a vraiment un gouffre en fait.
Si on y regarde de plus près, la déchristianisation, ce n’est jamais que la traduction de l’anticléricalisme qui va en grandissant depuis le 17e siècle.
Mais c’est quoi, l’anticléricalisme, en fait ?
L’anticléricalisme est une défiance envers l’église, lorsqu’il ne s’agit pas d’une haine dirigée contre elle.
Les anticléricaux ne sont pas nécessairement opposés à la foi chrétienne,
mais ils cherchent à séparer la vie religieuse de la vie citoyenne, et ce afin d’éviter l’influence de la religion sur l'État ou sur la nation.
Ils ne sont pas contre la foi religieuse, c’est la religion en tant qu’institution qui leur pose problème.
L’anticléricalisme est extrêmement protéiforme.
Il existe un anticléricalisme aristocratique très ancien, par exemple.
Il existe aussi l’anticléricalisme libéral et rationaliste, dans la lignée de Voltaire, dont on a déjà parlé.
Il en existe un qui ne date pas d’hier non plus, c’est l’anticléricalisme gallicans
qui vise à réduire le pouvoir du pape et de réorganiser le clergé pour le placer plutôt sous l’autorité politique locale.
On en trouve les racines au Moyen-Âge.
A plusieurs reprises durant l’histoire, les gallicans ont oeuvrés pour une distanciation entre le Royaume de France et l’église romaine,
comme à la fin du 16e siècle durant la fin de règne d’Henri III.
Contrairement ce qu’on pourrait imaginer, ce mouvement a été populaire au sein du clergé français,
notamment entre la fin du 17e et l’arrivée au pouvoir de Napoléon début 19e.
C’est d’ailleurs au cours de ce bon vieux 19e siècle qu’émerge de nouvelles formes d’anticléricalisme, basé sur le socialisme et le communisme :
[die religion] ist das Opium des Volks écrivait Marx, ou en français :
“la religion, c’est l’opium du peuple”.
Selon Marx, la religion permet aux classes dominées d’accepter leur sort en se berçant d’illusions, et il est donc un obstacle à la révolution.
Cette période va de pair avec l’apparition de l’anticléricalisme anarchiste.
La voix de la femme, premier journal féministe révolutionnaire publié en 1896 en Argentine,
avait pour slogan Ni Dieu, ni Patron, ni Mari.
En France plus qu’ailleurs, la convergence de toutes ses formes a conduit à de multiples consensus sur le plan politique afin de réduire le rôle de l'Église et son influence.
En France, si la troisième république a marqué l’histoire avec la loi de 1905,
elle a été ponctuée toute son existence par des mesures anticléricales.
“Le cléricalisme, voilà l’ennemi” disait Gambetta à la chambre des députées en 1877.
Parmi les mesures les plus importantes, notons la loi du 27 février 1880 qui exclut les évêques du conseil supérieur de l’instruction publique,
la loi du 29 mars 1882 interdit aux prêtres de pénétrer dans les écoles pour enseigner le catéchisme,
la loi Nacquet du 27 juillet 1884 établit le divorce.
Aujourd’hui, l’anticléricalisme n’est pas mort, loin de là.
Il trouve même autant de défenseurs du côté des impies que du côté des fervents catholiques.
Ces derniers s’opposent à l’église au nom de leur foi, parce qu’ils ne se reconnaissent plus tout à fait dans les prises de position du pape, ni celles du clergé de manière générale.
Ils n’acceptent pas non plus que l’Eglise puisse ingérer dans la sphère privée, notamment sur la vie de couple ou sur la vie de famille,
sur lesquelles elle paraît à la fois archaïque et bien peu experte.
Les positions de Jean-Paul II hostile à la contraception, à l’avortement, à l’euthanasie, au concubinage hors mariage n’ont vraiment pas aidé.
Celles de Benoit XVI son successeur non plus.
Lors de son premier voyage en Afrique, le pape en avait profité pour renforcer la position du Vatican contre le préservatif sur un continent profondément impacté par le SIDA.
En 2005, il impose également aux séminaristes d’être soumis à une enquête pour vérifier s’ils présentent des tendances homosexuelles ou s’ils soutiennent,
je cite, “la culture gay”,
et le vatican soutient à plusieurs reprises durant les années qui suivent qu’il existe un lien entre l’homosexualité et la pédophilie dont les affaires secouent régulièrement l’Église.
Pour aller dans ce qui est plus général, on pourrait citer le refus perpétuel du pontificat à ouvrir les fonctions de prêtres, d’évêques ou de cardinal aux femmes à une époque
où leur émancipation est une question récurrente qui suscite l’incompréhension de beaucoup de fidèles, surtout que la religion chrétienne admet en principe l’égalité des hommes et des femmes au culte.
Une question annexe à celle-ci, celle du célibat des prêtres, revient souvent également.
Pour finir, l’Eglise n’a pas l’air d’avoir renoncé à ses prétentions dominatrices.
Dans l’encyclique Evangelium Vitae rédigée par Jean-Paul II en 1995,
le pape réaffirme la supériorité absolue de la loi morale dont l’église est la seule interprète.
Pour le dire autrement, le pape place son pouvoir au-dessus de celui des états,
et comme les fidèles ont l’obligation de conscience d’y obéir, il leur demande à sortir du cadre de la loi si lui obéir le rend nécessaire.
Bref, les catholiques eux-mêmes peuvent être anticléricaux, ils ont peut-être même bien plus de raisons que les autres de le devenir.
Ils contribuent alors, peut-être malgré eux, au recul de la religion catholique en France dans la sphère publique.
Évidemment, une autre raison du recul de christianisme en France, c’est le progrès scientifique.
Lui non plus ne date pas d’hier.
La 2e moitié du 19e siècle, qui voit émerger le Darwinisme en lieu et place du créationnisme notamment,
conduit à beaucoup de réactions de la part de l’église.
Quelques années auparavant déjà, en 1854, le pape Pie IX condamnait dans une bulle pontificale les sciences et la philosophie alors perçues comme des menaces.
En 1893, c’est au tour de Léon XIII de condamner le rationalisme et la critique des saintes écritures ;
ce faisant, et partant du principe que la science a parfois tort,
il vise la théorie de l’évolution et défend la chronologie biblique traditionnelle qui place à la Création originelle il y a à peine 4000 ans.
Il faudra attendre le règne de Pie XII, en 1943 pour être plus précis, pour que l’église accepte enfin la lecture critique des saintes-écritures
et pour quelle autorise par la même occasion d’autres traductions de la Vulgate,
version de la Bible qui datait quand même du 4e siècle.
Tout le long du 20e siècle, l’église catholique est en pleine crise moderniste, non consacré pour désigner ses dissensions internes liées à l’adaptation au monde moderne et scientifique.
Elle débouche même sur l’organisation d’un concile oecuménique en 1962, le 21e de toute l’histoire de l’église catholique, afin de mettre d’accord
traditionalistes et réformateurs sur la position à adopter face au progrès scientifique, notamment.
C’est le moment où l’on autorise finalement la liturgie en langue vulgaire, c’est-à-dire que l’on décide d’en finir avec la messe en latin.
En France donc, avant 1965, ni chants, ni prières, ni lectures étaient admises en français.
La fin du concile ne rime pas avec la paix interne : d’un côté, les réformateurs demandent plus tandis que les traditionalistes trouvent que c’est déjà trop.
Pendant ce temps-là, dans le monde extérieur, l’athéisme fait son bonhomme de chemin.
Les courants comme le structuralisme, le naturalisme mais aussi le marxisme, le féminisme ou l’anarchisme
ont beaucoup contribué à athéiser ou à agnosticiser la société.
Aujourd’hui, la part de non-croyant ne cesse d’augmenter dans le monde occidental et en extrême-orient, notamment en Corée du sud qui est désormais à majorité non-croyante.
Par ailleurs, moins on est pauvre et plus on étudie, moins on a de chance d’être croyant.
L’augmentation du confort matériel et l’accès à l'éducation conduiraient fatalement à un recul de la religiosité, ce serait alors un autre facteur de déchristianisation.
Pour beaucoup, croire en dieu ou écouter le pape, c’est devenu ridicule.
C’est du bon sens, quelque part. De ne pas le faire hein.
Mais est-ce qu’on n’est en train d’abandonner nos religions sans contreparties,
sans l’émergence d’autres qui viendraient les remplacer ?
Ce serait pas la première fois, pourtant !
Hey, c’est toi qui a envoyé Léa et Valentine couper mes arbres là ?
Ouais, c’est pour un projet perso.
Ok, tu leur dis de rentrer et tu me rends ma hache, maintenant ! Personne ne touche à mes arbres, la nature, c’est sacré !
Ça va, c’est que du bois…
L’esprit de la forêt va être en colère !
Passons rapidement sur ce point, mais il existe un retour de la foi chrétienne dans plusieurs milieux qui trouvent leur origine dans les débats sociétaux
comme le mariage homosexuel ou bien la fin de l’école privée à l’époque de Mitterrand.
Le pontificat de Jean-Paul II a aussi contribué à la création de nouveaux groupes catholiques.
Cependant, chez ceux-là, la foi est d’autant plus forte et affirmée.
Les 3% de catholiques pratiquants dans la tranche 18-29 ans dont j’ai parlé tout en début de vidéo sont bien plus fervents que leurs aînés.
Finalement, s’il y a de moins en moins de catholiques en France, ceux qui le restent dans les jeunes générations le sont bien plus fortement.
De l’autre côté, on a la science.
79% des français disaient en 2010 avoir confiance dans la science,
et 94% des français percevaient les scientifiques positivement.
Mais si ceux qui se déclarent catholiques au fond ne le sont pas vraiment,
j’imagine que ceux qui sont du côté de la science ne le sont peut-être pas tout à fait non plus.
Cela mène à une question centrale.
Pour les gens,
c’est quoi la science, justement ?
Parce que pour revenir à la question de base, désormais, force est de constater que la déchristianisation se superpose avec l’émergence de nouvelles formes de croyances,
que l’on pourrait parfois qualifier de néopaganes.
On a vu le retour du druidisme, du chamanisme, ou l’émergence de la wicca et des mouvements New Age.
Tous ont en commun un retour à la nature.
Parce que si le naturalisme est venu emmerder le christianisme,
il est autant mis à contribution du côté de la science que du côté de nouvelles croyances dites
“pseudo-scientifiques” justement.
Ça ressemble à de la science, et on peut parfois croire que ça en est.
Mais c’est à base d’énergies, de pierres, de bio et de naturel.
Vous étiez peut-être d’accord avec le bon sens que c’est de ne plus croire en dieu ou d’écouter le pape y a 2 minutes.
Et peut-être que désormais vous vous sentez insulter désormais car “oui mais tu comprends c’est pas pareil”.
D’ailleurs, la première croyance pseudo-scientifique identifiable comme telle est le spiritisme d’Allan Kardec,
qui apparait en 1857 avec un ouvrage appelé
“le livre des esprits”
dans lequel on pose les bases de “la science spirite”.
A l’époque, comme l'électricité c’est le nouveau truc du moment et que beaucoup ne comprennent pas trop ce que c’est, c’est ce qui sert de carburant.
Ça attise les fantasmes, on y associe tout un tas de trucs à base de science mal comprise.
Si cela donnait à l’époque des explications de bon sens, elles nous paraissent désormais totalement mystiques.
De nos jours, ce n’est plus l'électricité qui rend les gens créatifs sur le plan pseudoscientifique, mais on a d’autres gisements qui ont pris le relais.
Y a tout ce qui est quantique, aussi.
Dans la science-fiction comme chez les charlatans, ce terme a servi à expliquer tout un tas de trucs.
On parle même de “mysticisme quantique” pour regrouper toutes les pseudosciences qui cherchent à relier la physique quantique à tout un tas de choses qui souvent n’ont pas rapport.
La discipline la plus connue est surement celle de la médecine quantique, qui fait alors usage de terme comme “médecine quantique”,
“biophoton”, “incertitude d’Heisenberg” ou “dualité onde-corpuscule”
pour vous embobiner alors que tout cela n’a rien à voir avec les soins dont vous avez besoin.
Mais le nouveau truc à la mode, c’est la nature.
Alors je sais, c’est pas forcément super actuel dans le sens où le catholicisme lui-même y a puisé son argumentaire au cours des siècles précédents,
et c’est pas le seul d’ailleurs,
mais ça l’est dans le sens où le prisme a évolué.
La nature, c’est désormais le réchauffement climatique qui est une réalité scientifique,
qui nécessite alors des actions écologiques, et donc quelque part une façon de vivre particulière, un art de vivre.
Et là, le potentiel pseudoscientifique, il est énormissime.
Tout d’abord, vous pouvez le croiser avec l'électricité et ses fantasmes d’antan.
Vous obtenez donc le Reiki ou la magnétothérapie,
qui mélangent énergies et nature, avec parfois l’imposition des mains, rituel hérité de la tradition judéo-chrétienne et donc notamment du catholicisme.
C’est ce qu’on appelle du syncrétisme.
Le mélange ou la convergence de croyances.
La ficelle est grosse, vous ne vous êtes peut-être pas fait avoir.
Mais y’a plus subtil.
Le succès des médecines alternatives, dont on sait par la science que leur efficacité n’est pas prouvée comme l’homéopathie ou la lithothérapie,
repose aussi sur la croyance que la nature est forcément bonne et qu’un remède naturel est forcément efficace et préférable.
L’agriculture biologique, lorsqu’elle base ses pratiques sur l’aspect “naturel” des pratiques ou des matériaux utilisés,
peut paradoxalement conduire à la production de produits dit “naturels”
dont la toxicité pour l’environnement ou pour l’humain est plus grande que ses équivalents ayant recours à des produits dits “chimiques”.
Lorsque la nature est sacralisée, et que les croyances que cela engendre conduit à des pratiques sociales particulières,
c’est peut-être que l’on est en train d’assister à l'émergence d’une nouvelle religion.
Alors c’est vrai, ce n’est pas structuré comme le christianisme,
on ne trouve ni clergé ni rites codifiés.
Et les croyants n’ont plus la foi, cette donnée qui était un gage de ferveur et donc perçu positivement est désormais considérée comme une insulte.
Les nouveaux croyants refusent de se considérer comme tels, parce qu’ils sont souvent convaincus du bienfondé scientifique de ce qu’ils défendent.
C’est un point de rupture majeur.
C’est juste que la science officielle est gangrenée par les lobbies qui nous mentent et nous manipule,
et que la leur c’est la vraie qu’on cherche à le cacher au monde car ça dérange,
c’est machin qui l’a dit et s’il l’a dit, il a raison même s’il est le seul à l’affirmer et c’est tous les autres qui ont tort.
On comprend pas vraiment comment ça marche,
mais on est convaincu et si on est convaincu,
alors c’est que c’est vrai et qu’on est prêt à le défendre contre vents et marées.
Les autres, s’ils écoutent pas, et s’ils opposent des arguments rationnel,
c’est qu’ils refusent la vérité.
De toute façon, la science n’explique pas tout,
pis elle n’a pas encore tout découvert, tu verras un jour.
Ça, ça ne vous rappelle rien, sérieux ?
En tout cas, j’imagine que cela conduit à une autre question.
Au fond, n’a-t-on pas besoin de croire ?
Voltaire le pensait, lui qui écrivait que “si dieu n’existait pas, il faudrait l’inventer”.
Durant la période athéiste de la Révolution française, Robespierre initie le culte de l’être suprême, basé sur le déisme et les lumières,
qui cherche à remplacer l’église et combler le vide spirituel ainsi laissé.
Aujourd’hui, on dirait bien que ce quelque chose est venu combler ce vide.
Ce n’est pas les faux-prophètes qui manquent,
chacun défend ses miracles avec sa propre interprétation des faits,
ni les fidèles qui même devant l’évidence préfèrent les suivre plutôt que de remettre leur parole en doute.
C’est un combat d’autant plus dur pour la science d’aujourd’hui, d’ailleurs.
Lutter en son sein contre ceux qui affirment détenir une vérité qui n’en est pas une.
Désormais et plus que jamais, l’éducation scientifique, la vulgarisation et l’enseignement de la méthodologie sont des fondamentaux.
Et bien sur cette note tout à fait joyeuse, je vous invite à partager la vidéo, à vous abonner et à liker évidemment
et à nous rejoindre peut-être sur Discord pour discuter de tout ça.
Et je suis actuellement en direct sur Twitch.
Si jamais vous êtes adepte du Reiki, enfant indigo ou
spécialiste en biodynamie ou alors tout simplement chrétien,
chrétien vieille école, catholique, venez en parler.
Venez discuter de tout ça, ça pourrait être intéressant.
Et donc, du coup, tu crois vraiment aux esprits de la forêt.
Ah non non, pas du tout, mais, je n’avais pas envie d’avoir une cabane dégueulasse au fond du jardin ni que Monté se retrouve avec une hache à sa disposition.
J’ai cru comprendre qu’il avait un peu assassiné ta cousine Valentine ?
Ou c’est peut-être qu’une rumeur, mais j’ai cru comprendre ça.
Ou peut-être que j’ai rien compris.
Attends. Qui t’a dit ça ?
Bah c’est Florent qui me disait que oui, Monté, peut-être qu’à la saison dernière…
j’ai dit une connerie ?